hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander so today we're gonna do a
challenge video these keep getting sent
to me but i saw the title for this one
and i was like okay this one better be
difficult because the last few
challenges have been really simple
because they haven't been fun
try not to laugh or grin while watching
this hardest challenge ever that's
that's dot mp4 that is a type so let's
do this let's try not to laugh or some
no laughing no smiling i know i can't
smile you can't smile no no I smell but
no you can't laugh or grin you have to
have a straight face robot so I'm gonna
crack the first video alright one two
three
check your body
just put more
it's kind of for you Johnny soccer ball
the giant soccer ball one was the
funniest to me there you failed
I already told you like I'm the worst
person to do this badly I laughed I
liked anything like farts anything I
smiled a little bit times where I was
like oh my god I'm about to crack the
one Rosa headed that was pretty funny
but the soccer ball the giant soccer
ball what was the one that really yeah
that was that one
yeah yeah those we're good those we're
good that was a little bit harder most
of those I've seen before I love like
fails those those get me that's mostly
what these videos are our epic fails
that are supposed to that's like
America's Funniest Home Videos that are
trying to get us the laughs you know
well guys I think I did pretty well on
that challenge
Sally sucks balls figuratively and
literally so here we go
don't know no not if not this not this I
can't date although is that tea good for
you on your skin anyway guys if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
salamander Sally's channel Funches you
[__] your [__] on there and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement for things
such as honest tea honesty is great it
tastes delicious it's easy to unwind the
bottle
also if you have to give honesty to
someone what you can do is if you run
out you can pee in it and chances are
the color of your urine will match the
green tea and then you can you know give
it as a good present and sometimes women
just like drinking past certain porno
actors like doing it and I used to give
a whining tea but people really didn't
like that for some reason you just drink
my tea - I bought you Pepsi and you
drink me I didn't ask for Pepsi but I
didn't ask for any of this Sally I'm a
nice person good honesty